the life of Josephine Baker is a
dazzling rags to richer story of a
musical icon stage sensation and heroine
of the French Resistance who took 20th
century Europe by storm thank Janelle
Monae meets James Bond
[Music]
Ka was born Freda Josephine McDonald in
St Louis Missouri in 1906. her mother
had dreams of being a dancer but made a
living as a laundress we're not sure who
her dad was but we do know her childhood
was difficult she worked from the age of
eight and spent time as a living maid
for a cruel employer who made Josephine
sleep in a box in the basement
the East St Louis race riots broke out
in 1917 and Josephine left shortly after
to pursue her dreams of stardom she
worked on some touring shows but having
already been married twice by the age of
15 she moved to New York neither were
happy marriages but she kept Willie
Baker's surname
after landing roles in successful black
stage shows her Talent stage presence
and utterly unique dancing style got her
a reputation as a funny girl
Baker was then spotted by a scout and
soon after packed her bags and set sail
for petty
Baker adored Paris saying that the first
time she danced there it felt like a
frenzy took possession of her body
not only did Bigger have that je ne sais
quoi on stage she was also a sartorial
sensation and it was in Paris the world
first saw Baker's famously provocative
banana skirt for Rudy
skyrocketing to fame Baker embarked on a
world tour and opened her own Cabaret
club called Shea Josephine she became
one of the highest paid entertainers in
the world you can even buy a Josephine
Baker doll
Baker was now making serious money and
bought a luxury hotel suite she also
acquired a few pets parakeets monkeys a
tortoise a horse a goat a pig a
chimpanzee Kiki the friendly snake and
of course the diamond color cladded
Chiquita the cheetah who accompanied
Baker on trips to the cinema but animals
weren't her only love after a marriage
to her manager Giuseppe Pepita which was
probably for publicity and several
relationships with women in 1937 she
married the aptly named John Lyon in the
1930s she started to sing and star in
movies as if being a wildly successful
performer and cat lady wasn't enough
when the Nazis invaded France in World
War II Baker joined the French
Resistance while traveling she flirted
with diplomats to gain information
stashed papers in her underwear and had
secret notes written in invisible ink on
her sheet music Move Over
007 in recognition of a courageous
contributions Baker received the
resistance medal in 1946. Baker was a
shining star in Europe but when she
returned home to segregated America the
welcome was not so warm
in 1951 she made charges of racism
against the owner of the famous Stork
Club in New York City for failing to
serve her she was then targeted by
high-profile journalist Walter Winchell
who accused her of communism a very
serious charge at the time as a result
Baker was placed on an FBI watch list
and her movements in and out of the U.S
were heavily restricted by the U.S
government
she toured Latin America and the
Caribbean but her FBI file meant she
wasn't able to go back to the U.S until
1963 when she did Return To America she
spoke alongside Martin Luther King at
the Landmark 1963 Civil Rights march on
Washington
after another marriage this time to Joe
bouillon Baker adopted 12 children that
she called her Rainbow Tribe on the 8th
of April 1975 she starred in a
retrospective review in Paris Josephine
ababino 1975 celebrating her 50 years in
Show Business it was attended by
Princess Grace Sophia Lauren Mick Jagger
Diana Ross and Liza Minnelli to name a
few and it was a smash
days after this performance she died but
in the iconic fashion we've come to
expect from Josephine Baker she was
surrounded by rave reviews of her show
she continues to influence culture today
and in 2021 46 years after her death
Josephine Baker became the first black
woman memorialized at Francis Pantheon
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video